a few reminders for just for the course
in general so we'll be sending out the
project guidelines very soon as well as
different suggestions for projects if
you're still looking for different
project topics a reminder that the
homework is due homework one is due next
Wednesday and then homework two will be
coming out on the same day
further presentations today we'll have
around 20 minutes for each presentation
and people can ask questions and discuss
the papers throughout the presentations
just like during lecture and we'll we'll
try to sharply cut off the presentations
at even increments so that we can get on
to the next one also for those of you
that are presenting if there's an
audience question please remember to
repeat the question this isn't
necessarily for the purpose of the room
but for people watching the recording
then they'll be able to hear what the
question was either that repeat the
question or answer the question in a way
that that the question is apparent from
your answer yeah so those are all the
the reminders and information and we'll
start with the first presentation in a
couple minutes once we figure out the
theater net they're just starting the
paper review session so the first one is
meta-learning for low resource noodle
machine translation it's fine it's free
and Ryan hi I'm Sabri hi I'm Ryan
I'm Anirudh we're gonna be talking about
metal learning for low resource neural
machine translation so start off give it
like a brief introduction on the history
of like and I'm Chi progress so
historically like notion neural machine
translation was first faced off like
statistical methods for language
translation and then over the last few
years as deep learning it's got a lot
better models have moved towards nmt
basically using deep learning for NLP
type tasks and those have outperformed
statistical models on the vast majority
of like trans multilingual translation
pairs and then there's the issue that
still exists that for low resource
language pairs statistical models are
still outperforming because deep
learning is very data hungry so
[Music]
basically neural machine translation
first started off as just targeting like
large monolingual core processor like
starting just like English to German or
like just like English to French or
something of that nature
slowly over time different papers came
out basically treating multiple
languages at the same time in the
context of a single task learning or
learning procedure and then after that
they applied like direct transfer
learning methods so initially like
training a model in like English to
German and then fine-tuning on like a
different data set for like English to
French or something of that nature so
the idea here was that we could use
neural machine translation methods and
like meta learning for optimizing fine
tuning on low resource pairs so that
classification learning would go much
faster and much more efficient so the
way the authors first set this up as a
meta learning problem is that the first
have to define the tasks so the divided
into two sets one is the high resource
language translation task and then the
lower resource language translation does
so each task is essentially a
translation between two languages
whether it's like Spanish English or
French to English or in the low resource
case Turkish English so the idea is
during Mediterranean phase you sample
your tasks from these high resource
language translation tasks and then you
train on these and during meta test time
you fine-tune on these lower resource
language translation tasks now it's
important to note that these low
resource languages are lower resource
than the high resource languages but
they're still not true low resource
languages so the author's had to
subsample in order to mimic a low
resource settings
so typically if you were doing meta
training you're during the gradient
updates
would first occur on your training data
set for your task right so you're gonna
update your parameters theta to theta
prime using your training data set and
then you compute the predictions on the
test data set and then you take the
derivative of the loss with respect to
the original parameters theta to update
the original data but what this involves
is a second derivative and because these
guys are using transformers for nmt
transformers are larger models so this
is gonna be computationally very
expensive so instead what they decide to
do is a first-order approximation so
instead of taking the derivative of the
the gradient loss with respect to theta
they take the gradient loss with respect
to theta Prime and but they still do the
update on theta now the authors show
that these are roughly equivalent and
even in dr. Finn's mammal paper she
talks about how they are roughly
equivalent and the intuition behind this
is that the Rayleigh neural networks
locally are linear so the second order
derivatives tend to be zero in many
cases so that most of the gains actually
happen from these post update parameters
which are the theta Prime's cool okay so
we got this cool idea we're gonna be
using meta-learning for neural machine
translation so that we get these low
resource languages in this case like
Turkish and finish and we'll be able to
kind of perform better
my first metal learning on a bunch of
high resource languages so just kind of
to recap the the setting is we're gonna
meditate on some language right so for
example here we have a Spanish sentence
we're gonna be translating that into
English right
and then we're gonna also be then meta
testing on a low resource language like
Turkish in this case and kind of one of
the main issues are kind of a central
issue that the the authors kind of tried
to overcome with applying meta learning
to this particular problem is that the
the Mediterranean the meta test input
spaces aren't aligned or they're not in
the same space right and so that is to
say if we have a sentence like Spanish
in Spanish right and then we want to
take the word nombre and look up its
Spanish word embedding and that Spanish
word embedding is going to be trained on
some monolingual corpora in Spanish if
we look up that embedding we'll get some
embedding for nombre but then if we do
the same thing in another sentence in a
low resource language like Turkish we
look up a beam right that means named
roughly in Turkish right
when we look it up right we're gonna get
another embedding and there's going to
be no correspondence between those two
different word embeddings right and so
we want the embeddings you know in the
meta train
languages and the embeddings and the
meta test languages to be sort of in the
same space that we can really get the
most out of med train cool and so the
idea that the authors had to kind of
address this issue is what they call a
universal lexical representation and the
idea is that they're gonna have sort of
one set of word embeddings that they're
gonna share across all of these
different languages both the meta train
high resource languages and the low
resource languages at meta test time
okay so the way that they kind of go
about constructing this Universal
lexical representation is they first
train word embeddings independently for
all the different languages so all the
low resource languages and all the high
resource languages they get a set of
word embeddings and they can do this
using monolingual corpora and then like
word debecker whatever they want to use
cool so we get we're embeddings for all
these different languages and what
they're gonna do is they want to create
this set of Universal embeddings that
all the languages are gonna share and so
but they do actually they just take the
English embeddings right but then they
also have this set of what they call
Universal embedding keys and the idea is
that these are gonna be like lookups to
look up values in the Universal
embedding values right so if a word
embedding is close to one of the keys
that means that the corresponding value
in the universal embedding values
probably like has a lot of weight okay
cool
awesome
so how do they actually go about using
this so going back to this example with
the word nobody we take the word nobody
right we look up the Spanish word
embedding just like before except now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna pass
that Spanish word embedding through a
linear transformation and then we're
gonna compare it to all of those
different keys and the universal word
embeddings keys right and what that's
going to produce it's gonna produce this
vector right that gives us like a match
value like or how well the Spanish word
embedding matched with all the different
keys and we're gonna call that vector
alpha right so each of the keys now has
this one scalar value telling us how
much it matched with the word embedding
in Spanish then what we can do is we can
multiply that alpha by the universal
embedding
I'll use remember those are the
universal embeddings that we're sharing
across all the different languages and
that's equivalent to doing sort of like
a convex combination or like a linear
combination of all of those different
embeddings in the universal embedding
values cool so the idea is that the
words the word nobody in Spanish is
gonna now be a combination some weighted
sum of all of the different embeddings
in the universal lexical representation
the cool thing about this is now we can
do the same thing with edium right but
the advantage is that so while Adam kind
of means named in Turkish and Turkish we
decline nouns and so that means that a
demon kind of means more like mining and
so maybe you could imagine that when we
do this linear combination we're gonna
give a little bit more weight to also
the word like I or the word my right so
this is kind of this flexible way of
having this one Universal representation
and then at train time they hold they
freeze the weights for the Spanish word
embeddings they also freeze those keys
which are just English word embeddings
and then they allow you to train those
universal word the universal word
embeddings and they also train that
transformation matrix going from Spanish
to the universal embedding keys cool so
one of the first experiments they ran
was to show how does this perform versus
a multitask setting so in both the meta
learning case and the motor tasks case
the first train their model on all the
high resource tasks and then they
fine-tuned on the low resource tasks so
what we the first thing that we do see
is that the meta learned model
outperforms the equivalent multitask
model across all categories so across
all the low resource language tasks now
it's interesting note in their diagrams
the way they split this out so they have
all embedding plus encoding and then
just embedding so what's going on here
is that they're not in the all case
they're fine-tuning all the parameters
while in embedding plus encode the
encoder they're just fine-tuning that
portion and then they also just
fine-tune the embedding so over here
what's happening is that most the gains
happen when you find Q in both the
embedding plus the encoder as opposed to
him fine-tuning the entire model and
this is interesting to see because the
decoder typically in an MT model
going from one language to another
language here all the tasks are
translating to English so the decoder is
taking the encoded representation of
some language and then translating that
to English so it's better not to fine
tune that portion because that's not
that shouldn't that part shouldn't
change it's mainly the encoder and then
the embeddings okay so one of the one
other thing to mention here also so they
also when you're doing metal learning it
can also be useful like to have actually
a validation meta tests task right to
determine when to early stop during your
méditerranée and so what they do is they
actually just compare different options
of which metal which of these low
resource tasks they uses that validation
metal learning task and so they kind of
show that that choice is actually
significant and that the performance
varies depending on which which
validation and task you choose yeah and
then the next experiment they do is they
try and vary the amount of training data
they have in order to compare between
the multi task and the meta setting meta
learning setting and as the hypothesis
suggests when you have lesser training
examples like in a zero shot setting or
a few shots setting the multi task
models or the meta learning models gonna
do a lot better but as you keep
increasing the size of your training
examples slowly at the gap between the
multi task and the meta learning model
the gap reduces so both perform almost
quibbling okay cool and so then here
they also kind of ask this question of
how does our performance vary after
fine-tuning depending on sort of which
languages we use during that battle
learning phase and the main takeaway at
the IDE here was basic the more
languages the better writes the more
languages we used during meta learning
the better our performance after
fine-tuning was but kind of an
interesting study to do there the other
kind of interesting takeaway from from
this from this table is that last row
right there which has fully supervised
so one thing that we mentioned at the
beginning was that these aren't real low
resource languages
like Turkish for example is a lower
resource language than French maybe
right but it certainly isn't like the
lowest resource language so compared to
like real low resource languages like
bear bear like Basque or something right
these are actually pretty high resource
languages and so to simulate the setting
of low resource languages what they do
is they sub sample the tokens in these
low resource languages like Turkish and
Finnish right and so when they actually
do like fully supervised training on
that full set they get blue scores that
are way higher than what they were
getting with these sub sampling which is
to be expected but it also begs this
question of like well why didn't you
also validate this method on on like
real low resource languages right I
think it would be cool if they had for
example like yes some case study for a
really really low resource language like
bear bear and then push the
state-of-the-art
on that particular language as opposed
to just like doing the simulated setting
where they're where they're kind of
under sampling from from these different
medium resource languages yeah I mean I
think what Sabri Singh makes a lot of
sense because like if we were going to
build product to do language
translations on low resource tasks at
least with languages that they show it
doesn't seem like the meta nmt model is
what you would use because it's clearly
not the best-performing model any
questions
got it okay so I think the question was
how does the universal lexical
representation get around the low
resource problem and I think that way
that I see it is like the universal
lexical representation doesn't directly
address the low resource problem what it
does is it creates the setting in which
all of these different languages that
have totally different vocabularies
often different orthography also right
what it allows you to do is allows you
to kind of embed all these languages
into a similar space which then makes
meta learning more effective and the
meta learning is what's really
addressing the low resource issue well
so the key thing here is that while like
for a low resource language in neural
machine translation we're usually
talking about low resource in the
sentence that we don't have a lot of
parallel corpora right so I decide we
don't have a lot of text where we have
like you know Turkish text and then also
English text but you might have like a
lot of monolingual corpora that you can
train those working lettings on so those
we're embeddings could actually be like
kind of decent I think that's kind of
the idea
so like sorry the idea that like oh like
in the in the sorry the question was
what makes me think that the languages
are linearly related I don't know if I
think that languages are linearly but I
think that's kind of like a question but
like sort of this part of there this
part of their approach yeah I mean I
think the idea is that basically like
each one of these rows in the universal
lexical representation doesn't represent
like a specific word as much as it
represents like some of like semantic
notion right and that different words
could be combinations like a linear
combination of different in semantics
like ideas kind of like yeah like with
like I deem it means like my name so
it's like yeah during the presentation
but one of the critiques that we were
thinking of while reading through this
paper is this transformation matrix a is
shared across all the different
languages for the embedding keys and so
there is an implicit assumption there
that along these along the same
subspaces that these keys belong to that
they're undergoing the same
transformation so that was like an
implicit assumption that they could have
gone around by using different
transformation matrices for the
different keys yes yeah I think when we
meant something what that actually is
during the fine-tuning phase so for
example like when they're comparing
against multi test model they don't fine
tune on all the available data they only
find tune on a subsample of the data in
order to simulate the low resource
comparison yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
Sood yeah if if you're talking with the
so both during Mediterranean and meta
test we're gonna be doing the language
translation task so any of the embedding
lookups that happen during meta trained
wall to happen to remind attest we had
one slide up there which was like we've
come up three like froze some weights
maybe that kind of gave the impression
that we were using them after meta
learning actually what we're doing is
we're freezing them for both meta
training and meta testing right so the
other weights were just like learned
they were like learned in unsupervised
way they were ever betting's mostly and
then we're learning all the other ones
like in both meta training and meta test
[Applause]
yeah so the next talk is a few short
autoregressive density estimation and
it's been presented by Rohan and where
everyone I'm Rohan and this is Warren
and we'll be reviewing this paper on
towards learning to learn distributions
to get started we wanted to talk a bit
about the motivation so why would you
want to learn distributions so
generative models in general learn
distributions and you could use it in
many ways you could use it to enlarge
your data set maybe for some data
augmentation you could let's say you
have some missing pixels in that Obama
image there you want to fill those
pixels you could use a generative model
for that all you have a specific
application like a capture thing and you
want to
certain images you might use this learnt
distribution for that and I guess the
main theme of this paper is that we as
humans are able to like if we are given
a few images we are able to generate a
new image or understand the latent
structure of what is happening in that
image and the hope like the idea in this
paper is basically to do the same can
you learn to learn these distributions
in a few short setting so the learning
setup would be this a task would be
defined as something like given a
support set of few images can I generate
a new image which looks similar to the
support set and for that like we will
have some training tasks so for in this
case you have an image of a bicycle or
you have an image of image a few images
of cups and you have a test task where
you are given these few images of like a
sewing machine and you the hope is that
you want to generate a new image which
looks something similar to the sewing
machine and the authors in this paper
rely on two major techniques one is the
neural attention and one is meta
learning so we wanted to take a step
back and talk a bit about some
prerequisites which will help us
understand the models that the authors
talk about the first is the auto
regressive models these are types of
generative models which are basically
use this assumption that there is a
sequential ordering when you factorize a
joint distribution into a set of
marginals and pixel CNN is an example of
an auto regressive model by by that I
mean that I will be generating these
pixels in a sequential fashion so over
here if I am talking about generation of
pixel X I I would use all the pixels
that I have generated so far which are
shown by the blue thing like all the
blue boxes here and what would I I have
an architecture which is like very big
deep architecture of a lot of
convolutions and some residual
connections and so on but the idea is
that I would do a feed-forward
generate a new pixel and then do it all
over again
and so on so forth this is the third
concept which we'll be using this is
called I mean attention most of you
might be aware of this but basically
there is a query vector and a set of
keys and values and in this case you
have a sequence to sequence architecture
where you are using the hidden states of
the encoder as keys and the hidden state
of the decoder as values and you get a
weighted average as your attention
vector so in order to solve this problem
the baseline model that the authors talk
about is called as conditional pixel CN
n now what do you mean by before going
into conditional what do you mean by
conditional pixel CNN the the
architecture that they use is called as
the gated pixel CN n instead of the
normal pixel CN n why do they do that is
because pixel are n ends were shown to
perform better on generation tasks and
why that is the case is because they
have some multiplicative units which are
modeling some complex interactions and
the authors basically changed the pixel
CN and architecture to a gated pixel CN
and architecture where they're having
these like gating of mechanism by having
that sigmoid which acts as a gate and
the tan h which acts as an activation
the conditioning here is basically let's
say I am given some information about
the image that I would like to generate
maybe it's a description I can convert
that into an encoding for example
something like H here and I condition on
that so my generation is conditioned on
that as an input in our case are like
going back to there are tasks which
where we had a set of support images and
we would like to generate a new image
which looks similar to the support set
we could potentially say that the
support set acts as a given information
to me and I could encode it by this
function f of s now F of s is some
convolution function which does like
some encoding and you apply the gated
function and you condition based on this
V set of equations so this acts as the
baseline model for generation
images so given some support set I'll be
able to use this model to generate an
image but there is no some sort of like
a concept of learning here like there is
learning per task but then you are not
you won't be able to generalize that
well so the authors proposed two models
the first model is called the attention
pixel CNN and the key idea here is that
as in when I am generating these pixels
I want to focus on different aspects of
my support set so my support set is
let's say 10 images I want to let's say
I'm generating the tenth pixel I want to
focus on different pixels from the
support set as compared to generate like
generation for the 11th pixel so how do
they model that is via this CNN based
architecture which is computing some
keys and values and then they have an
attention mechanism where they do this
transformation and learn their attention
weights and there are two major
important points to note here one is
that the author's augmented the support
set with some additional features which
represent positional data and the second
point is that you are learning these
weights but you are not like for a test
task like a given new task of flex that
say 10 new images you will not learn the
weights or update the weights you will
use the weights that you have learnt
before so there is no gradient steps
happening here the next model that the
authors proposed is called adds a meta
pixel CNN which is basically using the
concept of meta learning in a slightly
different fashion where the framework
remains the same but the key distinction
is that they they have this notion in in
like meta learning you have this notion
of the outer loss and the inner loss the
outer loss is modeled as the normal like
negative log likelihood but the inner
loss is something which is learnt so the
G function here represents the inner
loss which is basically taking in the
output of the fixed pixel CNN and
generating a scalar value and
scalar value acts as a loss and now I
would let why don't talk a bit about the
results and the takeaways from the big
everyone so yeah so some of the tasks
something in the experiment session they
perform three different tasks in order
of increasing difficulty they first
performed image inversion then character
generation and then finally image
generation the datasets that they used
were image net Omniglot which is
basically characters from 50 different
languages and stanford an online product
dataset which basically for each product
there's a variety of images that
correspond to it so some of the
evaluation metrics that they used for
this paper were qualitative and
quantitative so qualitatively they would
look at the output of the model and
determine if it looked good or not and
quantitatively they use Nats perdón so
as a review nats is a effectively a unit
of information or entropy based on
natural logarithms and powers of e so
one that would correspond to the
negative natural log of 1 over e and in
this paper basically they looked at the
net the negative log likelihood and
averaged it across all the pixels so for
the first task they performed one shot
image generation where the support set
was this dog and basically they try to
invert the dog as you can see the
conditional pixel CNN and the meta pixel
CNN didn't perform as well as they're
proposed attention pixel CNN and
quantitatively we can see the results
reflect the same thing one of the things
that they noted from the attention pixel
CNN's performance was that the attention
head learned to effectively move left to
right while the output was writing sorry
moved to learned right to left while the
output was writing left to right which
is a naive approach of inverting the
image the next task that they did was a
few shot character generation so if you
look at the first two rows you can see
that the support that for for support
images they were able to generate
characters using three different models
quality qualitatively we could see that
the attention and meta pixel CNN I
performed the pixel CNN
these are some of the quantitative
results they tried it on different
support set sizes over all the attention
pixel CNN outperformed the conditional
pixel CNN and even performed the current
state of the art at the time in addition
they tried a different model which they
didn't really talk about in their in
their model section which is the
attention meta pixel CNN which is unique
and but unfortunately it didn't perform
as well as just the attentional picks
Lucien n will discuss about it later
so in addition they even provided
basically how the samples are generated
and basically where the attention
weights are with respect to the support
images as they're generating each
character finally the third test that
they performed was a few shot image
generation so given few images they
wanted to understand laden the latent
structure of the image and try to
generate a similar product and sometimes
so they compared with attention and
without attention and the results they
argue that the attention mechanism is
better but it's questionable and they
even and if you look at it
quantitatively it's like the difference
is marginal
they argued that based maybe there needs
to be a better metric to do this sort of
task or to measure the sort of task so
some of the takeaways we'll break it
down into strengths and weaknesses the
strengths attention is great for
flipping images especially in the
one-shot generation case and this seems
to be one of the what this is one of the
first papers that we've seen that where
we can use a we can apply a matter
learning okay so I'll just continue so
the the meta generative yeah so the meta
generative models so basically someone
one of the another strengths is
basically they can apply a met and
learning framework awesome around
generative models to generate unseen
characters and then another cool thing
was that they were able to learn the
our loss function in the meta learning
framework some of the weaknesses
basically a few shot image generation
needs a new model from just the results
it seems that this approach probably
doesn't work well and they didn't
provide an analysis of the inner loop
gradient steps versus performance it
would have been nice if we had seen that
maybe it would have helped the meta
learning algorithm perform better and
then finally the sorry they added they
had some knife combination of metal
learning and attention this is also
strength in some sense because this has
never been done before but it would have
been nice if they explore this idea
further maybe there's some there's a
model out there that could perform
incredibly well and finally they had
inconsistent experiments specifically
with the meta learning and attention
based model they only applied it to one
task it wouldn't ask to see it on all
three tasks and with that I like to open
the floor for discussion and any
questions if you have any questions
please feel free to talk about them but
just to start I guess some discourse
yeah sure
right that's a very good point and like
I mean we were also thinking over there
is no control so the question was that
this loss there Vlad is learned is not
constrained in any manner so it could
just be learning to be emitting out as
zero but I mean we were also thinking
about the same and there is one of the
points here the last point here about
whether this loss function should be
constrained in some fashion but we asked
the authors and we'll talk about that a
bit later and it turns out that I mean
the loss the the the network G in itself
is differentiable and also you are
minimizing over that and because you
have some bias terms and stuff like that
you could prevent it to be zero so like
you it might be possible to constrain it
to be zero then you wouldn't have yeah
that is another point I mean the outer
loop would not see any updates and
that's why that could be another
intuition we haven't thought about it
from that perspective it's good point
any other questions right but I mean you
could potentially so the question was
what prevents the network from just
copying this net the images from the
support set because you have this notion
of like performance across tasks
you wouldn't like get very good
performance or like the loss function
would not go down if you are just
copying
yeah I mean but right that's a good
point but then if you see all the images
all the images are slightly different
from each other so if it just copies
like one thing from one image and other
thing from another image the final
generated image would not make sense at
all
so that's why it has to it's learning of
in in our opinion I think it's learning
a proper distribution of the objects
that are sort of important in that image
because they all the images are slightly
different from each other you can't just
like pick and copy one of them and also
an interesting point was that that Ron
made earlier was that in the in the
attention based pixel CNN the augment at
the data set to include positional
information and we're and basically
augmented it for I guess the meta pixel
CNN and also the the conditional based
pixel CNN so we think maybe the
attention learned basically how to flip
the images by looking at that augmented
component which is basically the
positional dimensions that make sense
[Applause]
yeah so this one is one shorter mutation
learning it's by yeah okay hello my name
is Shawn this is Dan we're gonna present
the paper one-shot imitation learning to
kind of describe the problem set up a
little bit and motivation imitation
learning is pretty commonly applied to
isolated tasks to kind of reproduce
you know demonstrations we see if
different things but we have this desire
to learn from a few demonstrations if
we're gonna try and learn a new task and
instantly generalize to those new setups
that we might see in this specific paper
the authors ask us to consider this case
where there are infinite tasks to learn
each with various instantiations however
in the paper they have this kind of like
narrow scope of that which is this like
robot robotic arm that is given like two
pairs of demonstrations and it where
each task is to stack blocks that are on
this table and a different permutation
and a different numbers of towers so
here it's trying to stack various blocks
on top of each other in the policy which
is kind of like our test time to match
what's going on in the demonstration and
oh sorry cool to kind of like over how
we split this up into train and test in
the train state you know we get this get
a pair of demonstrations we have one
full demonstration we look at with it
with attention and then from the other
demonstration we have one state from it
that we sample and we compute this
optimal action for that state and we
compare it to like the optimal action
for that state for the unseen kind of
policy that's how we compute our loss
and then during test time we are also
showing a new demonstration for a new
task we I mean the task will be
something we haven't seen before so some
new permits
and blocks that we have to stash in some
different order or in some different
number of towers and we got some state
we can feed some action for that state
and then we run this loop multiple times
until we achieve some terminal state to
talk about how we implement the
architecture or how the authors
implemented the architecture of this
there's three neural networks that are
your computing these these different
embeddings and taking different actions
there's the demonstration that worked
the context network and the manipulation
network to go through them one by one
and the demonstration network it
receives as input some trajectory some
demonstrations directory which is a
sequence of frames taken from the camera
of the robotic arm or is some embedding
from the neural network that analyzes
the images coming from that robotic arm
its output is an embedding of a
demonstration to be used by the
subsequent a neural network and its
architecture the size of this embedding
depends on the the number of time steps
in the demonstration as well as the
number of blocks on the table so the way
that we kind of capture info up or the
way we make this problem tractable and
this neural network is we we use
temporal dropout because we might have
like thousands of time steps within our
observation we throw away 95% of them
randomly and then we use a dilated
temporal convolution to capture
information from the past but focusing
more on the more recent time steps we
then use neighborhood attention to map
these is like variable dimensional input
into an output representing number of
query heads in the context of attention
that have the same number of outputs as
we have inputs so it's really important
I guess the next network is this context
network which takes in the current state
the observation from our camera as well
as the embedding produced by the
demonstration network and it produces a
context embedding which kind of will
tell our manipulation network like what
what context is to a form what action we
have to take so it is important for the
final network that
input is a fixed dimension so basically
the context network traps all of the
context we have in this variable e is
the size dimension input into a fixed
size output and the way we do that is
temporal attention which produces a
vector whose size is proportional or
basically it removes the dependency on
time in our output vector so we're only
dependent on the number of blocks now
and then when we apply attention over a
current state and we produce fixed
dimensional vectors that are no longer
dependent upon the number of blocks in
our state and the intuition behind like
why we're able to remove kind of like a
lot of information in these like
variably sized national vectors is that
the number of relevant objects is
usually small and fixed for instance if
we have this robotic arm were trying to
pick up blocks we probably only care
about the block trying to pick up and
the block trying to put it on top of and
finally BIM to the manipulation network
is the simplest network of them all it's
a simple multi-layer perceptron
basically it takes in some context
embedding and produces some dimensional
output vector representing the action
for this robotic arm to take one of the
the things that the authors leave open
is the potential for modular training
here so if you have some specialized
tasks where you can effectively train
this manipulation network it doesn't
necessarily need to be trained in
parallel with the rest of these networks
it can be more highly specialized and
that's a solution for one of the
problems they notice later on which is
where a lot of the errors they encounter
in training are just because as a result
in Mis manipulation so it'll not like
some block off the table and it'll be it
like some irrecoverable failure so you
go through like just broadly we have
some demonstration we it's a series of
frames we've applied temporal dropout to
it we apply this temporal convolution to
it to kind of attract the mote to focus
on the most recent steps we apply a
neighborhood attention such that we can
produce this like availably sized
embedding we apply our contacts network
to some bedding to remove the pendency
zhan time steps
and the number blocks on the table and
then finally that context the bedding is
passed into our manipulation network
which takes actions to move the robotic
arm to kind of stop here in briefly
summarize and discuss one of the
questions I had about once I read this
paper was that like stacking blocks on
top of each other to me might not
necessarily be a meta learning problem
if the only like difference is like the
order in which or the permutation which
you're supposed to stack the blocks or
the number of tabs you're trying to
create what do you guys think is this a
meta learning problem or yeah thank you
that's a pretty good answer yeah I think
there's definitely potential for for
that kind of thing here too if you guys
have any thoughts on you know whatever
other kinds of tasks this could
generalized to this problem set up I'd
be you know curious to hear if not we
can go into the experiments and results
question done becomes this how does this
model perform so the authors try to
devise experiments that could answer the
following questions listed here so the
first thing they wanted to answer was
what happens if they changed a training
scheme so the two training schemes that
they tested was behavior cloning and
dagger and for those of you who are not
familiar with the terms by behavior
cloning what we were doing is we're just
literally directly learning trying to
learn to policy using supervised
learning but by dagger what we're doing
is we have an expert that is
demonstrating these trajectories which
we initially try to learn from and then
after that we also gather trajectories
that are agent that our learn policy is
performing and then we check those
states and ask the expert to perform to
like give the good actions to like label
them and then we're gonna add that to
our data so that really like interacting
with the expert as we're learning so
that's what we're going on with dagger
are repeatedly aggregating data so these
are the two training schemes that we
want that the author is going to test
the second one they wanted to answer is
what is the effect of conditioning on
different data so if you remember back
to our network what we were doing was
looking back to the whole demonstration
and using that as the input so what
happens if we just look at the very last
frame or what happens if we are allowed
to look at only key frames which the
author is manually selected so how does
that affect our results the last thing
was of course how does this generalized
as this network learned to generalize so
this is the setup
they had different training and test
tasks each with two to ten blocks of
different layouts and then they
collected about 1,000 trajectories per
task using a hard-coded policy and they
compared four models the first two we're
using the same architecture that we
introduced but using two different
training schemes to be very cloning and
dagger and the third and fourth one is
uses a slightly different input the
third one only looks at the final state
of the trajectory while the fourth one
looks at different key snapshots of the
whole trajectory so I just want to stop
here a bit and ask if anyone has any
idea and they're like expectations on
how these models to defer or like how
they perform and yeses if not I could
just proceed and report would happen but
just looking at this definitions what we
could guess is for example because of
the third one and fourth one we are
looking at only so
set of the whole trajectory that's
probably gonna be faster right
and also we might expect that if we only
look at the final state which is the
final and image that you want to achieve
as compared to the whole trajectory
maybe the performance will not be as
good on the other hand if we know what
are the key steps that we have to follow
maybe it's gonna be using the data
efficiently that the model actually
performs better so those are some of the
guesses that the authors made before
they proceeded with experiments and
these are the actual results of the
experiments there's kind of a lot of
colorful bars here but the x-axis is the
number of stages required to achieve the
task at hand the number of stages so for
example one it just you just need to put
the block on top of the other and so on
so it's it corresponds to difficulty of
the problem the y-axis is the success
rate so how successful the models were
and performing these tasks and in terms
of the policy from left to right we have
the hard-coded policy behavior cloning
dagger only looking at the snapshots or
the keyframes and the last one is only
looking at the final state yes you can
make a few observations the first
observation is that behavior cloning and
dagger actually seems to perform pretty
much equally so that there hasn't been
too much benefit from human intervention
or the hard quality intervention with
dagger the authors assumed that this
might be because we are already adding
noise to the data they do not really
specify what noise was but they're
adding noise to the trajectory so they
assumed that this might be what's what
why we were able to learn well and
another point that we can see is that
the snapshots and final States they're
actually performing not too well which
is a bit surprising for snapshots and
the authors again assume because we're
if you remember we were doing those
temporal dropouts we're dropping 95% so
we're doing some kind of regularization
already when you're training so that
when we actually get the data we kind of
know how to deal with it so those are
some possible explanations and the this
one was for the training tasks and this
one is for testing tasks as you
obviously would imagine they perform
much
but the story is about similar here the
intuition that you get from these roles
is about the same and another fun chart
here is how looking at how attention the
first across the blocks so the x-axis we
have different blocks a 2j and from the
y-axis starting from the top we have the
time steps across the policy so like as
a policy carries on which blocks we are
paying more attention to and the one and
the configuration that we want to
achieve is ABCD efg hijk which means
that we want to block a on top of Block
B Block C on top of T which is on top of
V and so on so if you look at this plot
it's actually kind of interesting
because they are actually blocked into
blocks so in the beginning we are
looking at a and B because we have we
know that if you have to put block a on
top of Block B and so on so these are
actually kind of well separated and kind
of well demonstrates intuitively that
the model is looking at the right blocks
at the right time that it knows what to
do so this if you recall what are you
talking about so they had two attentions
one attention was looking at different
blocks they had another attention
looking at different time steps of the
demonstration so this is what we're
doing here so the x-axis now instead of
blocks we have different time steps of
the demonstration of buy that was shown
to the model to learn and a y-axis is
the same so here we see that again we
have these separations in the beginning
we have we are focusing on this
beginning time steps and that might be
because the model demonstration actually
moved a B in their earlier time steps on
so on so this is kind of in terms
interesting in that they show what these
a patient values are and it makes
intuitive sense when you look at the
plots and they also broke down what kind
of failures they had in terms because
you know none of the models are perfect
including their hard-coded policy so
they have three types of failure the
wrong move many politian failure and
recover old failure a wrong move is when
the final result is just wrong the
second one is manipulation failure
when the robot basically for example it
drops the block on the tape from the
table so it just doesn't know what to do
and the third one is recoverable failure
which is they make a mistake which they
could have fixed if they were given time
so one example was they have been
building a tower and they were trying to
pick a block up and they just crashed a
tower and over time they would fix it
but they did not finish it on time so
those are some different failures that
they catalyze down to and you see
they're actually not that many wrong
moves
it's the plot is very hard to see but
the summary is there weren't actually
that many wrong moves except the case of
when we condition the final state and a
lot of them were manipulation failures
so they just need to manipulate the arm
better so in terms of takeaways and
strengths it seems like learning a
family of skills actually make learning
performing relevant tasks easier in this
case stacking the blocks and it had an
interesting breakdown of modular
structures if you remember there were
three modules some results just like
that attention one was very intuitive
and clear and the neighbor attention
which they introduced allowed them to
translate input a variable size to
weights a variable size as well and
single-shot result is actually rather
impressive of you can look up the videos
in your own time if you feel like it and
while not presented in this paper the
data was actually collected using
simulations not real life images and the
person was demonstrating using VRS so
that was actually kind of cool as well
some weaknesses that we could think of
was this is kind of the weakness of
imitation learning itself is that we
have to assume that there are successful
demonstrations that read that the model
could learn from and that is not
necessarily always the case and if the
demonstration is not ultimately if it's
just running around fooling around and
that's what our model might learn so
that's some limitation just innate
imitation learning and as we've asked
before the tasks are quite similar so it
is a little bit questionable if you can
say hey this is meta learning it's
definitely a step in it but it is still
arguable and all Gurdon just doesn't
know what to do when we have a block
just something for and things like that
there were some other assumptions and in
the actual paper itself if you read
through the paper they're actually not
that many equations of descriptions
there are a lot of natural language
descriptions that is kind of hard to
comprehend what the network is actually
doing unless you read the actual
algorithm which is like a full page in
the appendix and they only discuss the
single experiment which is stacking the
blocks so it'd have been nice to see
what other tasks could have been carried
out using this scheme and also they
actually never really defined what
action is in this paper at least we
could from what we could read so that
was kind of sad so these are some
further questions that we could think of
and we have some dis questions as well
and we could go into discussion
questions but as we're almost done with
times there any questions we'll be happy
to accept them right now so is this
super clear sorry right so that'll
depend on the network structure as well
as the neighborhood attention mechanism
so that's what allowed us to have like
variable length of inputs and so for
example like at the attention of a
demonstration at that stage we'll have
still variable lengths but after context
network then we would end up in us
aggregated fixed size dimension that
they could like process and go with the
action like a cheese action yeah
okay yeah so the next presentation is
massively multitask networks or the
discovery and it's being presented by
Andre Western and Justin hi I'm Andrew
I'm Weston I'm Justin and we'll be
presenting on the paper massively
multitask networks for drug discovery so
the first question that we have when
reading this paper is what is drug
discovery as that we're not in
pharmaceutical engineering or anything
like that so the goal for pharmaceutical
companies is going to be something like
they have different drugs that are
testing out in an effort to find some
attractive molecules for further
optimization but the problem with this
is that there's a lot of different
compounds and their interactions are
pretty complicated and so one of the
ways that they try to go about doing
this is by automating the process using
machine learning and the goal there is
to predict the interactions between the
different targets and the small
molecules that are present within their
compounds so for example in this data
set like the dude in ha the target might
be to find which of the active molecules
might be targeting the you know
reductase so for studying this as a
machine learning problem one of the
motivations is that the data sets are
extremely imbalanced in fact only one to
two percent of the screen compounds are
active against a given target and we
know that these kind of extremely skewed
distributions can cause our machine
learning algorithms to have problems the
second is that there are very disparate
sources of experimental data across
multiple targets and so there's 259 data
sets altogether with 249 tasks but as
you can see here there are different
classes of tasks that we have and
there's not perfect overlap across these
different data sets with the different
tasks and so it becomes an interesting
case of like what kind of information is
present in each data set and each task
such that the algorithms are able to
profit from multi task learning and
finally it's least in the domain of
drug discovery prior work is unclear
whether asked to multitask learning is
actually beneficial in drug discovery so
there was a cattle competition in 2012
but one of the criticisms to the model
that was the winner in this competition
was that they had too small of a sample
size and the gains and predictive
accuracy were too small another paper by
unter thinner was that the performance
gains were positive but then there was a
different paper in 2006 by orhan which
said that all multi task networks did
not consistently outperform single task
networks and so this paper tries to add
an extra data point in this literature
of multi task learning oh and whether
asked to it actually is better than
single task networks so to give an
overview of the method the first thing
is necessary to do this task is to
figure out a way to feature eyes
molecules as that's what our datasets
are they're molecules with whether
they're active with a specific target or
not and it turns out prior work has done
this before the paper and there's a way
to future eyes molecules by looking at
different points on the molecule and
looking at what it's connected to and
having embeddings for different molecule
pieces and then sort of hashing them
together into a fixed length vector and
the way the method works is it takes as
an input layer this fixed length
representation of molecules using the
embedding talked about in the previous
slide and it feeds it through several
hidden layers one to four with a
variable number of nodes the paper tries
several different architectures with
different variable number of nodes in
each hidden layer and at the last layer
it's a very simple multi task network
it's just a different softmax node for
each particular dataset so most of the
parameters are shared and it's only at
the last layer where you have task
specific parameters
so they try to understand how their
models are working through a number of
experiments to answer a bunch of
questions which are how do you multitask
neural nets perform relative to
baselines how does adding more tasks
affect accuracy on a held in set of
tasks would we rather have more tasks or
more examples
how does adding more tasks affect
pre-training accuracy and then when do
datasets benefit from multitask training
so experiment 1 how do multitasking
neural nets perform relative to
baselines basically they just train a
bunch of simple machine learning models
on each of their tasks and then compare
their multitask networks to those
baselines so the first 5 lines here are
four simple baselines logistic
regression random forests and two
simpler neural nets and then the max
here is just the like task wise mats so
taking the best model for each task and
evaluating those and then they train to
multi task networks and show that those
multi task networks do better the first
one just has a single hidden layer of
length 1,200 and they note that this is
not the best design because if your
final hidden layer is 1,200 long then
each of your soft max nodes needs to
have 1,200 parameters whereas if you
have a two hidden layers where you have
2,000 in the first one and then 100 in
the second one then you only need a
hundred parameters per soft max layer
and so that allows you to avoid
overfitting to individual tasks in those
soft max layers so then an experiment -
they ask how does adding more tests
tasks excuse me affect accuracy on a set
of held in tasks so they set this up as
they train a bunch of models on the same
10 tasks and then add a variable number
of additional randomly sampled tasks and
observe accuracy as a function of the
number of additional tasks so the things
that can happen as you add more tasks to
your model are either you kind of
increase your accuracy continually as
you add more tasks you plateau as you
add more tasks
you don't really get any gains on
accuracy or you go up for a while and
then back down and some amount of tasks
begins to hurt you so they run it on
some held in set of ten tasks and they
find that on average the accuracy
continues to increase over time but
notably for many of them the accuracy
initially decreases with addition of
some tasks yeah right so a task is
something like this so you have a
basically you want to know whether
something will interact with some target
so you have a bunch of different input
moral molecules and you're asking will
it interact with this thing so yeah so
each of these colored lines is in
different individual interaction and
then the black line with the confidence
interval in the middle is the average so
on average it continues to increase over
with the addition of additional tasks
but in many cases it actually hurts the
accuracy at first and then goes up and
in some cases it continues to hurt the
accuracy and it doesn't really recover
from that and matter how many tests you
add and they only really address the
average case here they note that
sometimes it decreases but they don't
offer any explanation of that which I
really would have liked and they also
choose these 10 tasks but don't analyze
any of the other tasks which I think
that this result is probably sensitive
to the tacit they chose and I would have
liked to see it on all of the tasks kind
of different types so then in an
experiment 3 they asked would we rather
have more tasks or more examples in our
data set and so here the x-axis is the
addition of new tasks the y-axis is
accuracy and then these different
colored lines are additional examples in
the data set and basically they both
help kind of orthogonal and you can see
there is train
in in both directions as you add data
points and as we had tasks which is what
we would expect
unfortunately the confidence intervals
here are really wide and I think that's
because they did the same setup as here
where they chose these just 10 held out
or held in rather tasks and evaluated on
those rather than evaluating on all
kinds of different tasks and so I wish
that they had done that to have some
more general as generalizable results to
all of their tasks and then finally
experiment 4 they asked how does adding
more tasks affect pre-training accuracy
so if you pre train a model on a bunch
of tasks and then use those ways to
initialize a model a single task model
for a new task how does that affect
accuracy and again they said that on
average it continues to increase a
little bit but in some cases it hurts a
lot and this time they actually point
that out and say we hypothesize that the
extent of this generalizability is
determined by the presence or absence of
relevant data in the multitask training
set and this is the only analysis they
give of this which I feel like this is
kind of an obvious statement that if
you're free training on something that
it matters how relevant the data that
you're pre training is and really I love
like the whole paper to kind of be
addressing this point that how do we
decide if data is relevant or not but
they don't they just say that sometimes
it'll hurt you and that's it cool you're
gonna talk about the last one so the
last experiments set of experiments they
do is to try to figure out when
specifically do datasets benefit from
multitask training so first way to
attach this is they create this metric
called active occurrence rates which is
basically for a specific data set and a
specific molecule they measure the
number of other datasets that that
molecule is also active in and they sort
of want to see if a molecule is active
in a lot of datasets does multitask
learning help that
trained better for a specific task than
it would if it's only active for like a
small number of tasks and as you can see
this graph sort of shows what the active
occurrence rate is versus how much it
helps the specific task problem for
doing multi task learning and while
there's it's a very noisy graph you can
see there's clearly a positive
correlation between what the active
occurrence rate is and how much it helps
to do multi task learning and in this
vein another thing they want to figure
out was is there a specific class of
target molecules for which multi task
training is more beneficial than any
other task or any other category of
tasks so they put them in these
categories and ones that didn't fit in
an obvious category they just put in a
miscellaneous category and each black
dot represents a specific target dataset
and it appears there's like not much
difference in what kind of benefit you
can get from being in a different
category although some of them do have
like marginal variation but in general
it appears this the benefit for multi
task learning isn't really that
dependent on which category it's in
alright and to give an overview of what
we thought the strengths of the paper
were primarily we thought one it's a
very detailed empirical analysis on real
world data which is always a good thing
in a machine learning paper they're able
to tackle a challenging problem with an
extreme data skew where you're doing a
binary classification but only one to
two percent of the input data is
actually active which is a very
difficult problem in general and they do
it well here they use a simple network
which enables for very detailed and
simple analysis and they're exploring
under what conditions multi task
learning produces positive and negative
results and have very thorough
experiments on this specific real world
problem and they also achieve results
using a multi task network that
outperform any other baseline that they
could come up with which is a positive
showing that this multitasking is
actually beneficial for this particular
type of problem but at the same time
there were some weaknesses as are there
in any other paper so the first weakness
is there was a huge correlation between
the data size and a number of tasks just
because for any given data set you might
find that it only has five tasks or
something like that and so you know if
you have 40 tasks but each data set is
only able to have five tasks in each and
there's not going to be as much overlap
and so that was a big limitation that we
saw in one of the or quite a few of the
experiments where if you actually wanted
to see what is the difference when you
have 20 task versus 40 tasks the amount
of data that you can actually have in
the 20 tasks case is gonna be very
different and very much smaller the
second is while they give us some good
intuition there wasn't much theoretical
justification when or when to not use
multi task learning obviously they draw
upon some level of like domain knowledge
and saying that perhaps these things are
categorized as certain types of tasks or
maybe there is some relationship between
the size of the data set and the variety
of a test that are employed but again I
think as an empirical paper it does give
us intuition but not so much I'm a
strong theory to go upon and lastly
where as we did praised the simplicity
of the network for this analysis oh we
all do also wish that they could have
explored all of the architectures given
that this is a real-world problem it
could be interesting to see okay how far
can we go with this drug discovery is an
automated process cool and then
potential improvements which are related
to weaknesses so both more theoretical
and more empirical results on task
overlap
and how that is going to affect our
accuracy maybe something like an
analysis of how covariance between
classes is going to help classes learn
from each other or something simpler
just like saying so we have these
different categories of tasks if we
train a single model that does all of
the tasks in one category does that give
us better accuracy than mixing all these
texts together and I think you probably
could have gotten some more fine-grained
results from doing that controlling the
training set size versus the number of
tasks so it would have been good to say
like control the number of like fixed XY
pairs that are going being fed into the
model during training time whether they
are on different tasks or the same x
value rather this is the same x value on
different tasks or the opposite also
comparing different architectures like
we said they only do this one very
simple embedding and the one multi-layer
perceptron setup and they do say that
their results are kind of dependent on
using these smaller second hidden layers
but they don't offer any analysis of how
it changes as they change their
architecture and then finally they could
have benchmarked against models from
related papers they say basically that
it's hard to do so they didn't do it but
I feel like there must have been some
result that they could have said
compared to some other model or some
other method that people are using
takeaways yeah so as machine learning
researchers and not chemists were
interested in what can we take away from
this in our own modeling so first this
seems to be the thesis of this paper
that multitask learning can yield
superior results to a single task
learning and that there is second there
is limited transfer ability to task not
contained in the training set they see
limited because they saw in some cases
and not others third multitask effects
stronger for some data sets than others
so it is pretty heterogeneous and it
seems to require some level of domain
knowledge if you are going to
multitask learning forth on the presence
of shared active compounds moderately
correlated will multitask improvement
again this this was in relation to the
fifth experiment where they saw that
like if molecule was in 30 tasks versus
only in five tasks then it would benefit
more from multi task training and lastly
the efficacy of multicast learning is
directly related to the availability of
the relevant data again pointing to the
fifth experiment I'm looking at just how
many tasks each data point is associated
with and that concludes our presentation
are there any questions thank you so
hopefully some of the limitations in
those papers will inspire some good
final projects for the class and I'll
see everyone on Monday